jugamos
qué puede haber más importante en esta
vida que transmitir valores y derechos
humanos que jugando es muy pero que muy
importante hay métodos más innovadores
pero somos muy pocas las personas que
viajamos a holanda intentamos transmitir
derechos humanos mediante el deporte en
nuestro caso mediante un balón
ese balón por estar hecho de fibra de
banana de hojas de fibra de banana o de
bolsas de plástico así que en el 2015
pensé que quería hacer un tipo de
voluntariado donde los derechos humanos
no se respetaran busqué y busqué y
encontré uganda un país donde la mujer
sufre una violencia brutal cuando no se
respetan los derechos humanos de las
niñas y de las mujeres así que decidí
un balón de fútbol unas botas un
avión y empezar a repartir deporte y
sonrisas en uganda al llegar allí me
encontré un paisaje desolador niños
bebiendo agua del suelo mujeres
maltratadas miseria mucho sida muerte
pero sobre todo una discriminación
brutal
hacia la mujer hasta entonces lo que
había hecho era volar y jugar al fútbol
evidentemente como no tengo un avión
pues intenté transmitir valores mediante
el deporte fue muy pero que muy difícil
porque la propia comunidad las propias
familias los propios vecinos impiden que
estas mujeres y niñas tengan educación o
incluso practiquen deporte con mucho
esfuerzo con mucha paciencia recibiendo
muchos no me sentía frustrada disgustada
no sabía qué hacer para convencer a
estas personas de que me dejaran
practicar deporte con sus mujeres con
sus hermanas con sus hijas sabiendo que
una semilla no germina al día siguiente
de ser plantada que los cambios
necesitan tiempo al final logré
conseguir esos no los transformé pues
vamos a probar
y conseguimos montar tres equipos de
fútbol uno de niñas y otro de mujeres
con sida y otro de niños fue difícil
porque recibíamos insultos incluso a mí
me decían warm en war lying estás
mintiendo tú eres un hombre no puedes
jugar al fútbol o haber estudiado la
universidad a pesar de eso mis chicas y
mis mujeres al principio se mostraban
sumisas poco entusiasmadas porque ellas
realmente no sabían a lo que iban pero
con cariño con tiempo explicándoles el
valor del deporte se convirtieron en
esto
pasamos largas y largas horas
compartiendo juego compartiendo la
pelota compartiendo compañerismo y el
fútbol tiene un poder transformador y
después de tantos ratos explicándoles
que que todos y todos somos humanos
porque yo intento que en juego en
hombres y mujeres niños y niñas de
diferentes tribus de diferentes
tradiciones conseguimos esto
[Aplausos]
bueno en yemen con tantos porteros era
imposible marcar un gol pero bueno lo
importante es pasar un rato agradable
con ellos y en la verdad es que es muy
importante que sepáis el poder
transformador que tiene el fútbol
utilizado como elemento de cohesión
social o escuela de valores como os
decía en nuestros equipos juegan
personas de diferentes tribus y en
uganda se hablan 54 lenguas 52 una por
tribu más inglés y swahili pero a pesar
de eso no hace falta nosotros nosotros y
nosotras nos entendemos y nos podemos
comunicar y gracias a eso conseguimos lo
que se llama el empoderamiento a través
del deporte a través de un balón de
fútbol y por eso recomiendo activamente
porque lo que hacemos en consorcio no
uganda se puede hacer en otros países
del mundo o en otros ideales porque
simplemente es utilizar el deporte como
un canalizador de cambio y es una
fórmula que dirige a estas personas a
las escuelas y las elige las aleja de la
prostitución de la de la tradición de
ser abusada sexualmente o laboralmente
tanto en uganda como en otros países que
lo necesitan del mundo como decía me
costó mucho
y estos equipos porque recibía el
impacto negativo de toda la gente que
nos rodeaba pero con mucho esfuerzo lo
conseguimos como decía niños niñas y
mujeres con sida
al final pensando y repensando extrapole
a esa fórmula a españa y actualmente lo
estamos haciendo haciendo también en
valencia con mujeres víctimas de
violencia de género y mujeres migrantes
pero lo que yo más recuerdo de todos
estos años que estamos trabajando en
uganda son las ganas de vivir de sonreír
de estas personas recuerdo por ejemplo a
una de mis jugadores uno de mis
jugadoras que se llama olive olive tiene
sida porque su madre la violaron y ella
no entiende por qué va a morir de sida y
va a morir porque no tiene acceso a los
medicamentos no tiene acceso a los
alimentos desayuna te come te y cnt pero
lo que más recuerdo de ellas es las
ganas de jugar al fútbol las ganas de
vivir las ganas de sonreír o el caso de
mi amiga betty quien le practicaron la
ablación le cortaron el clítoris le
cosieron los labios y ahora lucha
activamente contra la relación para que
otras mujeres no pasen por lo que ella
pasó y los ejemplos como el de olive
cómo
como el de betty son los que nos empujan
año tras año a viajar a wanda ya seguir
con su lucha ya impulsar las y animarlas
porque eso nos da fuerza a nosotros
mismos yo por suerte nací crecí en una
comida más libre y más igualitaria en
europa a las mujeres aún estamos lejos
de conseguir la igualdad real pero
estamos intentando llegar a ella poco a
poco al menos aquí no existe la
profesión de violador las mujeres no nos
arrodillamos para hablar delante de los
hombres podemos abortar podemos decir lo
que pensamos eso está muy lejos aún de
que pase en uganda y es una cosa muy
pero que muy triste ya mí se me se me
cae el alma a los pies cuando voy
jugando y vuestras realidades por eso
seguimos yendo año tras año ejemplos
como el de olive como el de betty como
el de mi amiga vez sí que trabaja en el
campo con sus hijos cargados en la
espalda y cuando yo le pregunto betsy
porque si tu bebé varón llora le atiende
rápidamente pero si es tu hija la dejas
llorar y me conteste me dice patricia en
uganda a los hombres
siempre siempre lo que desean en cambio
las mujeres hay que enseñarles desde muy
muy pequeñas a que nunca conseguirán
nada de lo que quieren eso es muy
desalentador pero ellas no conoce lo que
es la igualdad entre hombres y mujeres
por suerte en españa tenemos un sistema
que nos hace y nos dice que por favor
luchemos por la igualdad y hay vivos
ejemplos como el caso de isabel garcía
quien lucha activamente por el deporte
femenino o nuria coronado quien realiza
un periodismo con perspectiva de género
elena jiménez que con sus reportajes
televisivos da voz a aquellas mujeres
inteligentes y valientes que logran
grandes éxitos para sus países pero yo
pregunto es muy injusto que muchas niñas
desde pequeñas sacan mejores notas que
sus compañeros en los colegios pero
cuando llegan a la adolescencia asumen
los estereotipos de género como una
verdad absoluta y dejan de brillar
porque es algo que no les corresponde a
ellas les corresponde a ellos y no está
bien porque estamos perdiendo muchas
genias muchas descubridoras de la vacuna
contra el cáncer muchas deportistas de
élite quedarían grandes logros a sus
países así os pido que os unáis a
a esta lucha a luchar por la igualdad me
pasas la pelota
gracias
en uganda lo estoy intentando mediante
el deporte y con la ayuda de un balón
así que
el balón está ahora en nuestro tejado
pasamos a la acción muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
sí